Okay interesting fact time,
did you know that there are roughly
320 million users with some form
of color vision deficiency?
To put it another way that
means 1 in 12 men and
1 in 200 hundred women suffer from
some form of color blindness,
which affects men much more
substantially than women.
That also means that around 1 out of 20
users of your site will likely have some
form of color vision deficiency.
Now imagine telling your manager that 1
out of 20 users of your site will not be
able to complete the experience.
That seems like a conversation that
wouldn't go over very well, but
when we rely too heavily on conveying
information with color alone,
that's effectively what we're
setting ourselves up for.
To give you an example, here's a form
that I filled out previously, but
something's wrong.
Can you spot it?
All right, how about now?
Notice that the telephone
number field is underlined red
signifying that it's invalid.
But to a colorblind user or
a screen reader user,
this information may not be conveyed.
And because of this, you should always
try to provide multiple avenues for
the user of your site to
access critical information.
The WebM checklist specifically
states in section 1.4.1 that
color alone should not be used as
the sole method of conveying content or
distinguishing visual elements.
And that color should not be used to
distinguish links from surrounding text.
Unless they meet certain contrast
requirements which we covered in our
previous lesson.
Instead, the checklist recommends
adding an additional indicator
like an underline to indicate
when a link is active.
So an easy way to fix that previous
example is just to add an additional
message to the field
announcing that it's invalid.
When you're building an app, try to
keep these sorts of things in mind and
watch out for any areas where you
may be relying too heavily on
color to convey important information.
If you're curious,
you can use the NoCoffee chrome
extension to simulate various
forms of visual impairment including
different types of color blindness.
If you're relying heavily on
the use of color in your UI,
you may want to do a pass
using a tool like NoCoffee
to see if there are areas
where you can improve things.